Bueno, me pareció interesante el comentario.
Entonces lo vamos a responder y lo vamos a leer.
Dice, joven, dígame una cosa,
todo el que hace una crítica es de derecha,
Catherine Miranda es de derecha,
jubilado es de derecha. J. T. P,
se dijo, me imagino que es j. P.
¿Que es que llevaban 20 días? P.
Bueno, vamos a hacer.
Vamos a aclararle al señor una cosa,
el hecho de que el la mayoría de los congresistas,
bueno, todos los congresistas que nombró,
son de la alianza verde,
un partido que se nombra de centroizquierda
y que ha es ha estado
acompañando por años en movimiento progresistas
y las banderas de cambio
no quiere decir que todos sus eh afines
sean de centro izquierda.
Sí, nada.
Tampoco que todos sean de izquierda,
ni que todos sean de derecha,
ni que todos sean de un centro real.
Digamos que la alianza verde
no tiene una ideología clara,
ya que recibe a cualquier persona.
Sus banderas son anticorrupción, pero tiene a varios,
a varios políticos
condenados en diferentes departamentos.
Es gobernadores, exalcales,
etc. etc. eh,
podríamos decir que como había dicho antes,
que el Alianza verde es un partido de centroizquierda.
Lo vemos a congresistas
que se pintan eh a veces alternativos,
pero que no apoyan esas banderas
alternativas y progresistas,
y otros que son muy descarados
en estar en un partido de centroizquierda,
¿pero promueven las ideas de derecha
o las ideas de extrema derecha?
Era el caso de diferentes Concejales
acá en la ciudad de Bogotá
o era. El caso es el caso
específicamente
de algunos senadores y representantes a la cámara.
Ser de derecha,
izquierda o centro es no es pertenecer a un partido,
es tener unas ideas claras.
Podríamos decir que JP es una era,
una persona alternativa
porque apoyó el paro Nacional en 2 021,
apoyó distintas eh.
Digamos que distintos
eh discursos progresistas
durante su campaña al senado de la República
por la misma Alianza ver,
pero últimamente no apoya ningún discurso progresista,
podríamos decir que no apoya casi ninguno.
Todos sus discursos
son casi basados en los discursos de Nayib Bukele,
que es un tipo
que podríamos decir que es una centro derecha
o una derecha,
por no decir que es una extrema derecha, eh.
Digamos que no tiene el mismo pensamiento en seguridad,
no tiene el mismo pensamiento social en lo público,
no tiene el mismo pensamiento empresarial,
es un hombre, pues
te también apoya el capitalismo,
casi ya yéndonos al capitalismo salvaje,
entonces no podríamos decir que este eh,
este hombre es de izquierda
o tiene un pensamiento de centroizquierda.
Lo mismo pasa con jubilado que pintó en,
digamos, en tarimas,
pintó en diferentes partes en la campaña presidencial,
distintos discursos progresistas y apoyó al Presidente.
Hoy Gustavo Petro,
pero hoy le hace muchas críticas
a proyectos que inclusive ella apoyaba.
Lo mismo pasa con Catherine Miranda.
Cómo es posible que ella también en tarima,
en redes sociales,
apoyando distintas reformas,
inclusive antes De campaña,
de la de la campaña presidencial
y hoy salga a decir que no le parece
ninguna de las reformas
ni ningún escrito,
cuando la mayoría de lo que está escrito
fue lo que ella misma se paró en tarima,
se paró a decir en redes sociales
y se paró a apoyar en su plan de gobierno.
Hacer que así que ser de izquierda,
ser de derecha o ser de centro
no tiene que ver prácticamente
con el movimiento
hoy hay. Obviamente
hay que hay movimientos que sí son muy leales a sus
a sus ideales,
no como el centro democrático que es eh.
Digamos que es coherente a su ideal de derecha,
a su pensamiento derecha,
a su pensamiento ideológico,
o podríamos decir el pacto histórico
que es coherente en algunos partidos,
porque hay en algunos que se están separando como eh,
la alianza democrática amplia y otros.
Pero bueno, eso es un discurso aparte,
que son leales a su ideología izquierda,
pero eso no pasa en el en el centro,
que está representado mayoritariamente por la alianza
verde. Espero que te haya servido